this song you're going to do is called
landmine it's from the new album one of
the lyrics post is I'm burning my way
through a stoplight baby I'm fine I'm
just thumbing my way through a landmine
what is the landmine you could step on
at any minute sir I I I wrote this song
about
um being on the verge of like a mental
breakdown to where you just want to go
into the woods and just [__] get the
[__] away from everyone and never talk
to anyone ever again so it's about uh
you're about to freak the [__] out and
I'm thumbing my way through a landmine
trying to navigate my way through a
landmine which is too much [__]
depression all this [__] [__] and
then whenever you thumb your way out
you're in the clear this is called
landmine from your new
[Music]
album and
all my
friends take
V break
all perfect
pieces we
by
your and not
side I'm burning my way through a stop
baby I'm fine I'm just working my life
through
[Applause]
[Music]
a and
all my
friends
inv like
my
cigarette and
hold someone's
watching but so be Hest I fumble for the
thr of Fe in a s minut in
light and
outside I'm burning my way through a
stop
light la
la baby I'll fight I'm just coming my
way
[Music]
through if your Bey
s imagine how I must
[Music]
feel but if you're getting rid of it
maybe I I just keep someone
[Music]
s
[Applause]
[Music]
la la
la I'm buring my ways to
stop baby I'm
fine I'm just forming my way through a
land
[Music]
M wow what a powerful song Beautiful
Just
fantastic